tu sais, je regarde le mien
rapprocher les gens de vos amis
parfois même honnêtement étranges ces
pays pourparlers annoncent que je me souviens dans
au début je demande à certains de mes
là
demande aux proches des camarades de classe
tu m'es apparu une question et tu es apparu
il n'est pas là jusqu'à ce que j'attende que tu apportes
ok j'ai apporté je demanderai apporté non pourquoi
Je ne sais pas, j'attendrai
des gens bizarres avec une bonne éducation
diplômes scientifiques
Eh bien, je ne comprends tout simplement pas
pas besoin de comprendre ce qui se passe
nous avons un vaccin fiable et efficace et
Je veux le redire avec nous
seulement deux façons
passer par une période de maladie ou
vacciner mais meilleur prix rouge pourquoi
attendre
maladie grave, ses conséquences
s'il vous plaît soyez responsable
prendre toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
protéger
toi ta santé tes proches